le césar du meilleur espoir masculin est
attribué à rhodes par ado dans la tête à
haute ou juin jeune garçon très agitée
du juge des enfants nés du capteur tente
inlassablement de sauver dont on suit le
parcours éducatif de ses six à ses 18
ans qu'il s'agisse sa toute première
apparition au cinéma la diacre et de
casting détruits dans un lycée
professionnel
il faisait assez ap en menuiserie eaux
de la rivière trice l'évoquent les
jeunes héros du cinéma de ken loach
ce soir tout le monde ça va plus trop
bien mais là combien de temps déjà pour
parler de minutes
bon déjà je vais remercier l'académie
des césars de m'avoir sélectionné que
c'est déjà énorme et et je vais
remercier aussi bas déjà emmanuelle
bercot m'avoir choisie pour son film est
franchement de tout ce que j'ai vécu
jusqu'à maintenant je crois que je lui
dois beaucoup et c'est dur il ya trop
d'émotion et je vais remercier aussi les
producteurs parce que en fait ils ont
été beaucoup là avec moi et même sur le
film me disais moi c'est bien ce que tu
fais et où est mon courage et surtout
françois denis enfin les films du
kiosque franchement c'est des
producteurs que je kiffe et j'avoue
enfin nous avons envie de les remercier
après j'ai tellement de gens à remercier
aussi goethe a remercié sa femme d'avoir
repéré au lycée et a aussi remercié
mais attention jeu quand je dis je dois
c'est je le fais pas parce que je dois
c'est parce que j'ai envie hein
et je vais remercier aussi madame kamar
donc la cpu et à la fin
et à la fin je dois remercier ma mère ce
que celle qui qui tous les jours croit
en moi et et je sais pas comment
yeah